Chris Mannix saw the fight the senior
NBA writer boxing writers for Sports
Illustrated also the zone who joins us
on the program let me start there Chris
do you want to see a third fight between
these two I would want to see it if I
had my my druthers I would like to see
something happen in between specifically
the Tyson Fury Anthony Joshua matchup
which you know in addition to being the
biggest fight ever
in British boxing history is easily the
biggest fight that can be made in boxing
today that's the kind of fight Dan that
would sell out Wembley Stadium in about
35 seconds and and just be a monster
show so I would like to see it down the
line but you know I wouldn't mind seeing
Wilder you know kind of come back
against somebody first what did you hear
about Wilders corner throwing in the
towel was that the right move in the
seventh well there are multiple kind of
things that that interest me and as a
fact of the fight I asked Jay DS the
head trainer for Deontay Wilder who has
been with him every step of the way of
his career exactly what happened because
the man that threw in the towel was mark
Breeland who's the assistant trainer
with that group now Mark is the only one
there in that corner that has fighting
experience the former world-class boxer
in the 1980s a very accomplished guy but
he's not the head trainer and it's rare
if not impossible to have ever seen an
assistant trainer throw in the towel and
Jay said something along the lines of
well we operate more like an NFL team
where I'm the head coach and marks the
coordinator and he has more authority
but but that was strange all that aside
he did the right thing in that moment
Deontay Wilder can't win a decision
against Tyson theory Deontay Wilder
really can't win a decision against
almost any top heavyweight in the world
he's just not that that type of fighter
so if you watched that fight by the
fourth round you know that Deontay
Wilder is hurt you know those legs are
and you know this power is gone as a
result so if we can see it obviously
mark breelan can see it and there's
really no sense in while they're taking
a substantial beating over the next five
rounds if he has no chance at at winning
it making any kind of comeback with one
big punch if you were going to create a
boxing figure you you would you still
wouldn't even create Tyson Fury he feels
like he's created with everything he's
gone through being overweight being
suicidal being on drugs losing all that
weight coming back winning the
heavyweight championship of the world
how far did how far can he take this oh
I think he can take this to much higher
heights I mean he is now in a position
where if the politics of boxing don't
get in the way he can have one of the
great heavyweight careers and one of the
things that's plagued the great
heavyweights of the last 20 years has
been either a lack of opponents or the
the inability to make fights because of
the the fractured nature of boxing mean
Vladimir Klitschko spent over a decade
as a world champion a unified world
champion but I mean his fights often
went unnoticed because they didn't fight
anybody
it didn't happen he those top two your
opponents to face over the next 18
months man you know if Tyson Fury fights
and beats Anthony Joshua which is a
great fight and frankly not not one I'm
sure that he's gonna win but if he
fights and beats Anthony Joshua if he
fights and beats Deontay Wilder again
you know with his personality which is
as flamboyant that's any heavyweight
I've ever covered and what most people
tell me is the most flamboyant since
Muhammad Ali his back story you know he
has a chance to to enter the mainstream
consciousness it may be no way that no
fighter ever has since the days of Mike
Tyson yeah it was quite an entrance
you know he's licking blood off Wilders
neck he sings American Pie you know
almost the full song after the bout you
got a but just just in the side and
you've got to be careful with Tyson Fury
I did I almost got fired from NBC for
because of Tyson Fury because back in
the day I did
I was part of the broadcast team for his
first fight against I guess Steve
Cunningham was at Madison Square Garden
the theater and this is main network NBC
so you got commercial breaks there so
Tyson wins that fight by knockout at the
end of the fight he's ripping the
microphone away from me as I'm holding
on to it for dear life he's pulling it
away from me and he starts singing
another songs in the middle of it let's
just say after that I got a couple of
phone calls from network executives
they're reminding me that I'm not
supposed to go up the microphone you
never give up the microphone I've had it
yeah a couple incidents at the Super
Bowl on the podium where that happened
we're talking to Chris Mannix great NBA
writer boxing writer you got the Kobe
Bryant tribute that'll be at the Staples
Center I'm looking at all of the teams
that are giving the opportunity for some
of theirs some of the players to
represent these teams at this tribute
what do you expect to happen with this
yeah I mean I don't know honestly I'm
headed over there in a couple of hours
and I expect it to be incredibly
emotional you know I'm expecting this I
just based on some of the Instagram
stuff will probably see Vanessa Bryant
for the first time out in public I
really don't have an answer Dan I mean
it's just you got the Celtics who are
sticking around after the game yesterday
and you'll see a lot of members of their
team at that memorial and I think you'll
hear from a lot of different players and
certainly from LeBron once again and
it's just going to be powerful I mean
this this was you know like one of the
hottest tickets out there I mean they're
gonna see the Staples Center completely
sold out and it's just going to be a
really emotional scene and they're going
with two 24:24 Kobe's gone 24 and
Gianna's number was two so therefore
that's why we have the two 24 20 yeah
yeah I mean it's gonna be immoral for
both and certainly a memorial honoring
all the victims of that crash I mean
it's one of those things that you kind
of walk into with no idea exactly what
you're going to see except you know a
lot of Laker fans that a lot of a lot of
tears in the crowd thank you Chris we
appreciate your time
you got it Dan that's Chris man
Sports Illustrated and also boxing
writer and reporter for to zone for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on Direct TV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]